I understand that roadside is part of an
overall plan for you to make what two
features every year you know it's it
just sort of happened that way you know
ah we shot it actually we shot our first
film Madison County end of 2010 2010
m2010 so like September ish we finish
within four months we had our funding
for roadside so beginning 2011 we were
on set filming that and then you know it
just sort of happened where they were so
quickly you know piggybacked off each
other um my personal thought but you
know with Eric meant my writing
producing partner or not my writing
partner but he was a writer and director
was I wanted us to be able to sort of um
keep the fire going like we had good
things going with Madison County and I
wanted to be able to you know get I
really believe that we could get our
next feature off of the first one you
know and thankfully we that happened
because our we had investors who wanted
to put in more money for Madison but it
got to a point where it just wasn't it
just wasn't really worth us taking in
more money you know just financially
didn't make sense so we we just kind of
tabled their interest over into wrote
I'd you know pitch that and then
thankfully they went for that so we
removed on that and you know that was
the goal to keep on going and then find
something after now with roadside it was
a little bit more of a tricky situation
to find the next project because and
what I mean is to continue that fire
that I speak of because we were now we
had just filmed roadside and we were
still in post on Madison County and then
selling it and doing all those things
while we were in post with rosette so
now we had two films it wasn't like that
one was done and we move on to the next
so I personally was like I don't want to
take on a whole new feature till we we
have to ready on the unlit you know on
the burners here like I want to get one
done you know so and then we'll move on
to the next one um and then what
happened was you know you know we sold
Madison County and then roadside we were
working on and then Eric got another
film with another group of producers and
started working on that and then I
book the film in Columbia that I was
starring in I wasn't producing I was
just in it as an actor um and you know
we get work and that's that's how how it
is right you know so um we constantly
you know are looking at stuff Eric and I
are talking about developing not only
the second you know the sequel to
madison county but a new film together
and we both have friends who were
looking at you know sort of partnering
up with to develop content and stuff so
you know it's an ongoing process but
thankfully it got to a point where we
were sort of forced by our films to take
a step back because we needed to make
sure we gave the time to them that that
was needed i mean a lot of people don't
do that i feel like they have tons of
films and they just keep you know they
just keep adding them on to the slate
and it's just like will finish one thing
you know what I mean or at least you
know it's great to have 11 projects in
pre-production but like what does it
matter if one of them doesn't go you
know and that's that was me it's like
because I I'm an actor full time like
that's what I do you know and and
thankfully since I've been out in LA i'd
say like ninety ninety ninety-five
percent of my time out here in six years
yesterday was six years in fact um hey
wait that's all been acting work and not
even extra work just acting you know
other other you know like a camera
work but um so I've been lucky in that
regard you know what I mean and that's
what I do full-time so it was like
producing is also a full-time job plus
two you know so um I I'm very selective
with what I take on so there's another
film that I I'm in development for
helping with the the development team of
that and that one's called for blood or
justice um and then you know like i said
the projects with Eric and I that we're
sort of brainstorming and then my own
stuff like i have stuff with it with a
couple of other people and just scripts
of my own that i'm working on as well so
um you know II that was the eventual
plan to get something going once you
know you know follow up with something
each time but um you know you sort of
have to be able to sort of roll with the
punches right and I realize well that's
not you know that's not setting me up
for for putting out the best product you
know in the best way that I know so you
know I it was sort of one of those
things I was like okay I don't need to
be doing something every you know two
times a year or whatever it is if it
works out that way fine and it happens
where I'm involved with those
you know with those numbers than fine
but you know I wasn't going to to kill
myself over the idea of thinking I need
to have two films every year that I'm
producing because you know I'm
thankfully busy in you know my full time
job which is you know my acting work so
it's just how it worked out
you